[Applause]
[Music]
yes this episode of new releases is
dropping on April 1st no I'm not gonna
start off with some dumb joke about
half-life 3 coming to steam next week
but I am gonna tell you all about the
biggest games coming this month this
episode has a pretty wide scope and the
first game in its sights is Yakuza 6 the
song of life everyone's favorite thug
Kazuma Kiryu has just spent three years
in prison only to be released and find
his adopted daughter Haruka in a coma
after a hit and run cue the
investigation into what happened and a
new life for cure you and balancing a
criminal past with taking care of a baby
you'll be playing as cure you only this
time around but you should still expect
a bunch of crazy minigames and side
quests Yakuza 6 finally releases on ps4
outside of Japan on Tuesday April 17th
speaking of new dads let's talk about
God of War Kratos has moved north and
now he has a family at Reyes will
accompany him on this journey which sees
the Spartan battling monsters and gods
from Norse mythology
he's also traded the blades of chaos for
a battle ax and the game in general is
much more open than the rest of the
series with bigger areas to explore and
optional bosses to take down god of war
gets reimagined for ps4 on Friday April
20th until then we can reminisce about
punching Zeus in the face way too many
times
now let's talk about something more
kid-friendly Nintendo lab Oh takes your
switch in a crazy new direction with
cardboard peripherals you can build
yourself called toy cons there are
included minigames and blueprints for
you to play around with but you can also
build your own contraptions and program
all sorts of toy con functions with the
game's garage mode you can pick up the
variety kit for 70 bucks or 60 pounds or
the robot kit for $10 more but they both
drop on Friday the 20th and if you have
further questions you can check out a
preview from yours truly that goes into
the pros and cons of this unique idea if
you want something not so kid-friendly
on switch Nintendo's hybrid console is
also getting South Park the fractured
but whole this sequel sees the South
Park cast playing superheroes and as the
new kid in town you can customize your
own addition to the team and choose from
a variety of superpowers other consoles
got to fight crime last year but you'll
be able to take your switch to South
Park on Tuesday the 24th and that's not
the only big port coming to switch this
month naruto shippuden ultimate ninja
storm trilogy will be a digital a shop
exclusive that packs in all three ninja
storm games taking you from Naruto's
early days all the way through the
fourth great ninja war the package also
includes some previously released DLC
costumes and episodes though take note
that it's not every single piece of
extra content either way you can start
practicing your ninjutsu on Thursday the
26th and those are some of the hottest
games we'll be playing all month long as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with your regular
weekly episode of new releases next
Sunday